he is the champion quarterback of super
bowl 35 joining us here on the rich
eisen show after super bowl 56 none
other than trent dilfer how you doing
trent
that was a lot of hair ago rich
you and me both sir years ago i saw some
pictures this week some videos and i had
i was holding on for dear life for my
hair
you and me both sir you and me both bad
hair yours you and me both sir there was
uh the word of the day was rogaine you
know
i haven't heard that word in a while but
that's the word that was the phrase it
pays back in the day
amen you know okay so
i will just say what did you think of
the game last night what do you think of
that
my big takeaways and we can get into
this um
sean mcvay with one of his greatest
one of the all-time greatest coaching
performances if you look at it year long
that i've seen
we can go into that
and then the game kind of summed up
a lot how i thought it would unfold
bengals could do hardly anything
offensively really their whole offense
was two plays
in the passing game um both kind of
chuck and ducks one that should have
been called back
and a decently solid run game but not
much there in the passing game besides
two plays
dominant defensive
line performance by the rams and and
then really the big takeaway was the two
best players on the field playing their
best when it mattered the most cup and
stafford and i think that was
um really the
the sign off the drop the mic moment of
the super bowl was stafford who had
struggled from the interception the end
zone and his first five possessions in
the second half
really until that drive where him and
cub just kind of willed it and mcveigh
gave him the keys of the car and they
finished the deal six and a half minutes
to go needing 78 yards and uh and a
touchdown and that's what they wound up
doing leaving some time left on the
clock but um you know cup on that drive
the fourth and uh short run um with a
whole stadium had there i mean i was in
that spot that the whole stadium held
its collective breath uh on that one and
then obviously the throw to cup over the
middle uh over outstretched arms what a
dynamite dart
by stafford and then and then the game
winner the the the drive itself you
mentioned
about the the mcvay game plan for
changing up i mean they had to change it
up in the middle the minute that odell
went down right i mean that changed
everything it seemed to me in the game
it really did um
no i thought it was a little overblown
on the telecast that you know staffer
didn't have any weapons he still had
cooper cup
um you know it it wasn't like he was
left out there naked
uh i i think the rams did a really good
job mcveigh especially the play caller
kevin o'connell probably had something
to do this as well is in between series
when they were struggling because they
really struggled there for i think was
five or six possessions in a row
trying to find a way how do you call
plays or move cup around so he's the
primary on every play down the stretch
it's not as easy as you think
i think i i went back here's what hit my
brain
[Music]
nick saban tells us great story
one of the greatest lessons he learned
in football was when he was playing high
school football and they won a
championship and their best player got
the got the ball in the biggest moment
of the season and he always his takeaway
from that was players over plays
and you have to get your best player of
the ball in critical moments and i can
see i bet you sean mcvay and kevin
o'connell have heard the same interview
and they're like hey down the stretch
here we have to find a way that cup
touches the ball on almost every play
and to create some of that stuff on the
side link some i bet you some of that
stuff was not in the game plan it wasn't
like they had they had repped it during
the week
it was probably stuff that they put in
on the sideline and made adjustments and
then stafford has the ability the the
connection with cup to get him the ball
in some really tight windows
i thought it was crazy how the games won
i mean you quarterback sneak it on first
down from the one and a half one and a
quarter and then you throw a fade i mean
that's not a play sequence that you see
very often quarterback sneak fade like
that's it's usually quarterbacks need
quarterbacks any quarterback sneak then
fade on fourth down so i just think
mcvay at some point and i haven't talked
to him but at some point in that game
him and kevin got on the phones are just
like listen this thing comes down to
those two guys making plays and we have
to find a way to let them do it trent
dilfer here on the rich eisen show super
bowl 35 champion beyond the x's and o's
podcast as well to go inside this man's
outstanding football brain right here on
the rich eisen show what did you make of
the officiating in the the uh
the flags that came out at the very end
after 58 minutes of hardly seeing one on
the field
you know outside the egregious missed
call on the long touchdown that was um
besides that i liked how it was
officiated they let them play
and then people are saying why don't you
let them play down the stretch i mean
some of those i mean those were those
were bad calls too the whole the one
that they said there wasn't much there
uh across the middle on cup the middle
backer 55 holds them you can see him
hold his waist and pull them back i mean
when that when there's an
effort to
hold the player from getting where he
needs to get i mean that has to be
called especially in the tight red and
that's the other thing fans need to
understand the closer you get in the red
zone the closer the refs are to all
these plays so they have a better view
of them so
uh i had no problem with the officiating
outside of the one call that the the no
call when ramsay gets his facemask twist
i mean fans are always going to complain
about that stuff i get it players do too
coaches do but at the end of the day
looking at it from a 60-minute game i
thought it was pretty well officiated
trent dilfer here on the rich eisen show
okay so what do you how do you think
stafford's feeling this morning what's
that feeling like
obviously fulfilled uh i tell people all
the time i think you can talk to most
quarterbacks that win this game it's
more of a sense of relief
uh it's
it's more fulfillment
you're not
you kind of expect it i think every
quarterback that wins it expects to win
it i think that's one of the the things
that as i've talked to my peers
about it that you know you just convince
yourself
and your team
um that there is no other option but
winning this game so when it's over and
you do it you're just like well yeah we
expected to do it
it's not the elation that everybody
thinks it is um it's more just
satisfaction satisfaction you're usually
really happy for your teammates more
than yourself
and then honestly it doesn't take long
before you're like okay next um that's
how champions think is is no rear view
mirror appreciate the moment and then
move on to the next moment and uh the
next moments for the rams are going to
be challenging because of how they
invested into this season in this
particular game yeah i want to maybe hit
that a little bit with you in a bit of a
page turn in a second but lingering on
stafford a lot of folks
on this past week saying that the next
for him eventually when it's all said
and done is canton ohio now because he
if he got the ring now he does would you
think that's the case i think so i think
he's deserving of it i think people are
sympathetic of his detroit years and yet
he was still highly productive i've
always put stafford in this category a
guy that was at his best when he needed
to be at his best like he was playing so
many times from behind he had so many of
these heroic comebacks yes he put his
team in those positions sometime because
he tried to do too much in detroit but
he was always one of those top five guys
you wanted the ball in his hand down
four with 90 seconds to go
and he proved it i mean he did it in the
playoffs and and it wasn't 90 seconds
but he did the final drive in the super
bowl to win the game as well it's kind
of how he's wired
a lot of fave in him i've always felt
that was the best
comparison where they might make some
mistake they might make you scratch your
head sometimes but you trust them when
the game's on the line and
and i think he is worthy i think if you
win a super bowl and you are highly
productive uh i'm obviously not putting
myself in this category um but if you if
you win a super bowl and you've been
productive for a long period of time as
a quarterback you deserve to be in the
whole thing well i mean he was
hand-picked uh the minute that he
decided along with his wife to make that
maneuver maneuver to go into the lion's
front offices and say i want out he was
he you know less need and and sean mcvay
said that's the guy and then that's the
guy that
leads them to the podium and and i guess
now cycling back to the way you started
about greatest coaching
job year to year post to post wire to
wire that you've seen in a while from
sean mcvay what do you mean by that yeah
let me put a bow almost everything
because something hit my brain while you
were talking go for it there was a
lebron commercial in the midst of the
super bowl old lebron with a young
lebron
on the bed and old lebron says some of
the very end to be legendary you got to
bet on yourself
and i think a lot of people probably
just let it go by them but then you
watch stafford shortly after that
commercial
win the super bowl and it's exactly what
lebron said i mean
in this commercial stafford bet on
himself he put all the chips on the
table and said i want to go in a super
bowl and i'm willing to take some
chances here
and he did it and i think that you know
to your point that's why he will be
legendary and he'll be in the hall one
day
the thing with mcveigh is this
you could argue it's one of the greatest
most challenging
coaching jobs in the history of the nfl
and people are going to go what
well think about it think about him
unless need have done they completely
mortgaged the future supposedly that's
the narrative the nfl has has put on
them for sacrificing draft picks
to get players on their roster now to
then go win the game i mean they were
ridiculed
by quote-unquote experts
in league circles it's not the parcelian
way it's not the bella chicken
belichicki in way it's not
the 49ers way it's not it wasn't the
cowboys way um it's their way
and a lot of people i mean there was a
very strong narrative when they were
seven and four heading into week 13 that
this was the wrong thing to do because
not only are they not going to get to
the super bowl this year
but they have no chance in years to come
because they have no draft capital and
everybody in the nfl everybody all your
friends all my friends say the same
thing oh build for the future set it up
for the future
why
why wouldn't you have aaron rodgers
don't you
mortgage the future to get him players
now or tom brady or matthew stafford
there are certain moments where you're
like we have a very short window here
and we got to do it now and they did it
they took a huge chance
and it worked and there's a lot of
people around league circles this
morning that are pissed that it worked
because their paradigm has been
completely blown up uh the browns ooh
the browns are set up forever with all
this draft capital yep they're sitting
at home too and they're probably gonna
be sitting all next year and they're
probably gonna be sitting home the year
after that with all this draft capital
so i think that for sean mcvay you know
he took a lot of criticism for that but
the hardest thing is this the
personalities
the personalities in that locker room
obj von miller jalen ramsey aaron
darnold donald matt matthew stafford go
on and on and on
and to get all these big personalities
all the star power to come together and
if i say this all the time look at what
they talked about when the game was over
they didn't talk about oh we had more
talent they talked about coming together
being selfless cheering for one another
um being happy for one another
doing the hard little things day in and
day out the grind things all the stuff
that never gets talked about but all the
stuff that really matters sean mcvay is
the catalyst for all that he's the one
that brought them all together he's the
one that messaged it he's the one that
built the culture that obj can walk into
as a
supposedly disgruntled diva wide
receiver and be everything but that
um
like that that is a massive massive
thing that really really matters and
sean mcvay did it and then you gotta
think about this go back to the to these
to these coaches that won championships
belichick parcells walsh jimmy johnson
they didn't have the pressure on social
media
they didn't have every single thing you
do being blown up out there
and you know
10x the drama to it because everybody's
seen what's going on in your room i mean
he's had to deal with with a modern
media machine and social media with all
the negative narratives against how
they're doing that balancing all these
personalities being seven and four
leading the week 13 taking all the heat
and then guess what they do they win
nine out of ten and they didn't do it
um glamorously they did it gritty
and i i just i think it's one of the
greatest coaching jobs we've ever seen
trent dilfer here on the rich eisen show
couple more minutes left with him all
right trent let's uh let's go now to the
bengals side of it what next there just
shore up in front right and just uh keep
at it the defense was terrific defense
has been terrific defenses you know trey
hendrickson is a guy that many people
know and then outside of that nothing
you know the weapons look to be set
borrow looks to be
next level uh is it as simple as that
no i don't think so okay and i don't
i root for him um i was at one of their
weddings this summer so i have friends
on that team i love joe burrow i love
jamar chase
i don't think this is going to be a team
that contends every year they play in a
brutal division
with some of the best coaches in
football
they
i don't want to say luck that'd be a
terrible word they were very fortunate
to get to this game
um they let live by the hair their
chinny chin chin
i don't think they have enough
sustainable star power outside the two
big ones on offense i do think the
runner is pretty darn good
i believe consistency offensively is not
through stars it's through bigs
they're bigs just don't cut it and it's
not like you can just go find four new
ones
um i think this is going to be a team
that next year really struggles to get
back to the playoffs they may because
the quarterback's so good
um but i don't see this being a team
that year and in year out especially in
that division you just chalk them in
like you do the chiefs
as a team that's going to contend for
the afc no kidding yeah
damn trent these people are in the
they're they're they're in the the
football outhouse right now they really
feel it right and i'm walking out of
that stadium i was next to some guy just
said to me goes like i i can't believe
this happened to my team in the super
bowl again he goes i remember the last
one now this happened again i'm like
don't worry you got joe burrow but it's
more than that it's way more than do you
think the do you think baltimore's gonna
get worse or better they're gonna get
better
um
pittsburgh actually will be better
without ben um they're going to find a
solution at quarterback cleveland's
hard-nosed tough
don't know if they're a dominant team
but they're tough i mean it's just a
brutal division and then you have kansas
city they got by him once but do you
really if they played that game 10 times
and every listener right now outside of
bengals fan
how many times you think the chiefs win
that game i think they win it eight or
nine out of ten
and the chiefs are only going to get
better
the raiders i think are going to get
better i think there's a lot of teams in
afc that are more talented and are going
to get better and it's going to be tough
sledding for the bengals all right and
then last one what what about next for
the rams you already heard going into
the game that mcveigh's kicking tires on
on maybe media he's getting married and
aaron donald's uh said after the game
the retirement rumors that uh rodney
harrison put out there on nbc he
sidestepped them he didn't say that's
crazy he literally said i'm going to
take some time here uh what do you think
about the rams next i think the only
choice is to wait and see i mean there's
so many unknowns um i do think
stafford's gonna have to take less money
to if they want to keep it together i do
think you have some of your stars make
selfish decisions economically if they
want to keep it together
and i think that's step number one for
less need is start having those meetings
and figuring out the future um and then
there's a real possibility you may be in
a rebuild mode you know that you that
some of these stars move on
um you open up cap space and
and uh you start rebuilding um
but they they knew that going into this
thing right they they mortgaged the farm
to win this game and i in my opinion
that's enough they did it
i agree they'll just look at their the
look at their trophy right as as
everyone's on the clock on the thursday
night
uh in vegas they'll just say here's the
trophy oh the the malibu sunset is
gleaming off my trophy right that's
basically what they're saying
you know
trent thanks for the time uh look for my
call as we get into the talent value
evaluation portion of the campaign uh
beyond the x's and o's pod and then of
course everywhere on twitter at dilfer's
dimes thanks for the call trent you're
the best man looking forward to it have
a great day thank you sir trent dilfer
super bowl champion right here on the
rich eisen show hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here